[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want we got
gilbert back what's up
we got michael back hey mike can do my
channel
michael's from chengdu from the province
of chengdu i have been to chengdu before
but really i have what are your
impressions of it be honest about the
people hey look at me
they were like so like that's the
silicon valley of china right i don't
know about i think that's shenzhen or
something like that i don't know about
that like sorry oh definitely not the
silicon valley
first of all bart said it so that's the
silicon valley of china that's what i
heard i don't know that's what anthony
told me is when you go there it's like
mind blowing like mike disagrees i don't
i don't know so like um there's like
certain stereotypes about people from
china right like what like what let's be
honest you're very political i'm trying
to learn this about you yeah yes
uh yes
it's the stereotype dude so like the
stereotype about chengdu is that they
have really pretty girls really what do
you think about that it's definitely not
the silicon valley
that's not that's the opposite yeah have
you guys been to sweden
no no some hot ass [ __ ] in this room
i heard quote me i heard it
man
there's a restaurant
called chengdu impressions
and they have uh
gen there's chengdu taste and yeah the
sichuan yeah they're super spicy yeah is
chengdu
which one is it that sounds great
you're mixing it all up man
are you just doing a ken montana
yes i am i just watched you guys are
always pranking me
he's like i can't tell i'm pretty sure
it's like chengdu right is that right
that sounds mandarin
tender like tenses
something i don't know i don't know i
care like one second
speaking
the language without actually speaking
the language how good is if i say a
country doesn't have to be asian can you
do the gibberish version of that
so uh spanish don't say any spanish
words but give me the um
said if they did that
okay very good a little bit french
british like english british
[Laughter]
i know boy the food mate not so good
mate you gotta you say the words you say
the words it's hard that's better when
you know the english
we'll do more of your realm okay okay
okay do japanese gibberish
oh i know the word
filipino
for everyone to try
a couple of years
when you go vietnamese it's more that
they do so
can't make sure that [ __ ] you
know what a hard one is is try doing an
american accent or american gibberish
that's the hardest because we speak the
language steve this is
[Laughter]
my mom's impression of rap because she'd
be like always listen to that all the
time hers is this
mom that's tribal chinese
it's also a major league baseball champ
a very popular one i think is it indians
and the braves are they still the braves
and are they still they're still the
greatest indians the indians have
changed i believe oh really we're in
their process of i think they're done
redskins is football they're just
washington football team yeah what's
what's the indians is it arizona oh my
gosh cleveland indians oh cleveland
indians so they're gonna change their
name apparently is that what you guys
are saying yeah i think cuz i know
braves are still the braves which i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that cleveland indians they might change
and bart was saying the football team
watching the redskins is now the
washington football team which kind of
sucks wow no mascot the washington
football team no picture mascot logo
dude the picture's amazing they should
have called it they should have called
themselves like rainy suicides or
something right she'd be suicides
i like that actually that's something
about suicides the washington
i like that that's pretty suicide
because the adjective is is like is not
usually
for people i think that you're not in
the naming community yeah bro the
football team is better than literally
anything else honestly this is literally
like an aau team or not look at this
this is like a question they troll
themselves oh no
i like it why do they that's my brother
well because everyone got everyone got
max
before and now cleveland's changing
their name to the guardians the
guardians their last year as the indians
cleveland that's kind of cool
oh just to be like sorry it's better
than football team that's about the
suicide one that that was pretty good
like what joe said i think they should
have to change their name everyone
should have to change the name of the
jets
[Laughter]
every story every sport
if you have the shame in your team's
history to do this you have to be the
[ __ ] jets which is a really bad thing
by the way yeah nobody wants to be the
jets not even just want to be the jets
when's the last time they had like a
winning season in the jets
like 2011
and even told the wrong name they let
everyone down yeah jets aren't even that
cool as a mascot is that a plane
yeah it's a plane yeah i guess well
what's a laker i don't even know what
the hell that is the guy that goes
fishing dude really because i really
want to be honest no i don't know where
it was on lake michigan where all the
great lakes are in so long oh
yeah that's a
that's a lake but then we bought it so
we came over in the ocean we should have
the beaches the beaches where's the
mother beaches
oh why you should have a basketball team
oh they should be like it's just a
personalized kamikaze pilots i i didn't
say that what you wanted to say that's
not when i say it how [ __ ] is this what
exactly is a laker a person associated
with a lake
that's it that's it so you're telling me
the like the greatest basketball team of
all time is a laker is it resident of
the people that go to the lake that's
associated with the lake what's it gonna
do with the pacers dude
yeah what is that
what is a pacer
what is it they pieced themselves that's
the indiana basketball team but i don't
know what the [ __ ] a pacer is i think oh
i think it's gonna do with the car the
car um the indy 500.
there's a pacer car that's like that was
the head so they kind of call themselves
like the racers or something yeah that
sounds much better in my opinion
pictures can't even go faster it's like
running that's some old-timey [ __ ] bro
isn't it what's a clipper
yeah exactly what is the clothes they're
they're like fast boats that like went
from coasters mike why do you know this
dude cause i used to be really into
basketball history then what happened
not the sport
where did the shape and the patch the
patchness of the basketball coaster yeah
it looks like a net
that i don't know because i only looked
up certain random teams that are in los
angeles aka the the lakers and the
clippers okay okay clippers is because
ships used to pass through san diego bay
and they're called clippers
chen do mike over here chen do mike dude
damn they were so boring back then
nothing it's like the steelers the same
[ __ ] because steel town
they would make steel there oh
steel
warriors have no warrior on it well they
don't it's just that yeah it's a game
it's the bridge right the bridge is the
longest
yeah yeah i wanted to see like
somebody with a bow and arrow or some
sword or something on a horse with a
tomahawk that's a warrior that's a real
indian i'm trying to remember if like
they ever did those fake ones
yeah just a bridge they need to do a
full reba brand like san antonio spurs
it's just the back of a boot that's
pretty cool what a spurs though i know
but that's so dumb it's like the texas
soul and it's just the bottom of a shoe
with the rubber grip that's hilarious
yo you should start an expansion tape
owned by varquan the texas souls should
bring the nba out to las vegas you know
you should petition right there should
be they're trying to couch oh they are
they're trying to they're trying to take
because they already have the raiders so
no no there's two uh i think there's two
nba guys trying to bring an nba team to
las vegas and their plan is to build a
nba resort casino that can also have uh
play games so it's a hotel built into an
arena with like a hall of fame nba [ __ ]
what
so that's our goal it's not resort world
no it's not dude it's the opposition
the las vegas jokers
hey
that's pretty good i thought you were
going to say something smutty
i was thinking about a real team there's
a lot
las vegas methors
las vegas
the las vegas losers degens
oh the dj's is good
good yeah and then they can do this at
their basketball
oh that'd be really good today's video
is brought to you by hellofresh
check this out man i absolutely
love to cook okay i know you do i love
to cook but there's a few things about
cooking that i have gripes with number
one going to the store and grabbing
ingredients
and
more than number one number two number
three number four okay planning my meals
thinking about all this
now all this stuff is also fun but when
you are busy
because that's the tough part you got
things to do man
well i ain't got no kids or anything i
live alone but i still got things to do
okay i'm busy okay i got things to do
and i don't have much time and i can
only imagine if you're a single
parent out there or whatever go whatever
is going on with you you're probably way
more busy than me or a college dude or
something you you studying trying to be
a doctor we got a lot of asian fans here
i know you guys are trying to be a
doctor an actor right some something
with a terp right yeah and you're like
what am i going to do i like fresh
ingredients i don't want to go get junk
food but i also like
cooking and hearing the sizzle on the
freaking pan right good thing hellofresh
is here for your rescue because they
send you all the ingredients
they send you everything that you need
even an instruction you you choose what
you want and you're like you know what
this week i want to try this i want to
try that oh i'm feeling like chicken i'm
feeling like whatever right
you get everything in the box
comes right out and for for those of you
who don't even know how to cook the
instructions they come with every single
food they tell you step by step how to
make it right every single dish is like
they give you every single thing that
you need so you don't got to go to the
store it's thrown in your face and you
can make fresh food you can make fresh
food right at home that's what i love
about this [ __ ] and what i like about it
is that it's fresh it's pre-measured so
there's no food waste you know sometimes
you go hmm i want to make some curry and
then you get one potato and you get some
meat and you go to the carrot section
and you're like damn i gotta buy 50
carrots like oh well i guess i'll figure
out what to do with it later and you end
up using only one stick of carrot and
then you forget about it and you throw
all this extra food away so with
hellofresh you actually save 30
compared to if you just went to the
grocery store and bought a bunch of
random stuff you save money because it's
excess like some of the recipes that we
make with hellofresh it'll literally be
like a potato
one egg like things that you can't just
buy individually they'll pre-package it
that way pre-measured and all you have
to do is follow the instructions and you
even see a picture of what it's supposed
to look like that's amazing so if you
don't know how to cook it's like very
easy step by step chop the carrots heat
this now it has the specific order you
got to go in it's awesome so if you want
to get yourself some hellofresh go to
hellofresh.com off the record 14 that's
off the record 14 for up to 14 free
meals plus free shipping that's two
meals a day for seven days oh i didn't
know about this deal 14 meals that's
insane that's that's a lot of food yep
go to hellofresh.com
off the record 14 to get up to 14 free
meals plus free shipping go to
hellofresh.com wow they're just giving
food away they literally are dude have
you guys win in resort world it's huge
like everything is huge
everything is just big like hallways are
big like everything it's massive bigger
than what's already existing yeah damn
that's great
but everything is still building too is
this like is this like a new casino like
i haven't been to las vegas it's an
asian one right so i'm into las vegas
history okay
so the history of the resorts world
it's it's not a good one because it was
that unfinished casino that we've seen
for 10 years straight right next to
[ __ ] win right and then um
what first happened was during the
height of like the recession they were
they they started construction and then
they had to end it because like no one
was going to vegas by 2008 yeah
but it was to it was basically a casino
for all the asian clientele that was
coming to vegas and macau has yet to be
like what it is today
at that time so then um
a malaysian company i think bought it
from another company and then they were
gonna make it like you know this chinese
casino and then something else happened
and then now it's like split between
hilton and some other groups to finish
it yeah it's hilton yeah but it's like
hilton and another there's like three
hotels in one so at each branch is a
different
hotel and then um inside it's like a
night market an asian night market for
the food court did you eat there
yeah what did you eat holy [ __ ] it does
not look like that so that's
that's what it was supposed to be but
they're missing this part right yeah
yeah it's just that part right now yeah
what is that circular thing in the front
it's a bubble shop i hope it's a boba
it's pretty cool chinese yogurt it's
it's like a mall inside but was the food
good joe that's my i heard the food was
overpriced for a night yeah i heard it
it's to me it was okay i heard it was 20
bucks for a bowl of laksa noodle soup
yeah oh that sounds bomb yeah it's it's
got a lot of options it's terrible
yeah it's got a lot of options but i
don't know to me it was like it was will
that go on your cheap eats list no
no it's not cheap was it worth it to go
for the food and the value
for the experience just try it out maybe
what i chose because i got some beef
noodle soup i got some sushi i got some
like uh roti so yeah we got
yeah that's what's cool about it is like
you just go to a kiosk and then you
start ordering from all these different
booths oh that's cool and then yeah when
the when the boots ready like it buzzes
you and then you just start collecting
all this stuff my dream
i don't think so i think it was like
i think it was like they need work a
little bit because it was too um it was
like too salty and too fatty and too
much flavor yeah it's for white people
right there
you're always writing shots at me steve
so you know yeah
as he sits there with above me in a cafe
sit down i'm watching you all day but
this is the real stuff though so like
you know this is learn to appreciate the
real asian food right here in the sgv
wow when someone goes like when you go
when people talk about asian food when
you say like when they say like what's
the most asian thing you've eaten what
would you think of that
[Laughter]
we trained him we're so good though
authentically
with the little like
authentic like you just go to china yeah
the stuff in there was authentic i think
that they they didn't train the cooks
right
like it was made by like you could taste
the flavors but it's like it's off
so maybe in a couple months it might be
i think so i think so like it's just
everyone's like working that out but the
the thing that blew my mind was just the
size of everything like when you walk in
like vegas is already big like but i
feel like each time they try to out big
each other but then the hallways the
just from like store to store like how
much space there is in between
unnecessary would you say it's bigger
than a mall so i'm just like why the
[ __ ] do i have to walk a football field
to get to the other side of a hallway
they did rush everything um my friend
she was in charge of the interior design
of the place and like the day before
it was still there's still raw draw
drywall that's what it feels like to the
place looks like it's just
like undis like not coordinated like
it's it's trying to be ballin with a lot
of like wow factor yeah they're trying
to get she was saying like it's not
gonna achieve too many things
and um
yeah everything was last minute and
they've been on a 24-hour build schedule
for like the past like six months
they're still building dude yeah it's
crazy favorite biggest hotel what's your
favorite biggest website gotta go the
win right now i think they'll win
probably i'll win
or
well which kind
oh
encore
when encore oh there you go are they the
same thing i love the encore
but encore has more private is it
more private come on michael right what
do you mean i don't know what he's
talking about
right
yes we were there together five years
ago the last time that i went mine's the
circus circus in the wind why the circus
i know why
because it's the hyundai santa fe and
the g wagon
best place to people watch
yeah and then the wind is another it's
it's a it's a good place to people watch
but i feel clean there it's very clean
yeah i feel good
i i um i i you know steve wynn so he got
his start in the golden nugget i'll say
this i don't know who steve wynn is it's
the win owner of the win holy [ __ ] yeah
but it was right there
i don't know i don't know
you didn't know the connection
that's what i thought who's the steve
bellagio
steve
i would say that he is the designer that
everybody follows so whatever he makes
they all try to be like him so like he's
a money guy like what was his he started
with the golden nugget in downtown and
then his first hotel was the mirage
so then he he built that mirage and then
he's like nah i'm not done yet and then
he built the bellagio
and then those two now belong to the mgm
company because he sold those off and
then he built the win so if you go
through the progression like i like to
go to every single hotel to see how he
evolved and then you go win is like it
makes sense like it it's like bellagio
mirage all them put together into one
yeah yeah but each one like when they
finish building that was like the
benchmark of vegas yeah and everyone
tries to catch up and he's already on to
the next thing [ __ ]
what's the one okay i love arya but
that's the problem what no what's one
connected to it
the fedora dude that's the [ __ ] i like
the video is sick it's only like all the
rooms are sick and it's like all sweets
basically let's go oh i gotta check it
out does that one have gambling at the
bottom no no is that so it connects
right you have to walk super quiet it's
super quiet exactly that's why i liked
it didn't check that out but then you
can walk into the action like go right
across the street go to the art aria was
pretty sick too i like that
but i don't
i i gotta go super tacky
like excalibur or one of those or i just
gotta go like
like like posh or whatever like super
because the city center it's not themed
no it's not so like the win even i feel
like i'm in a different world like
you're around expensive art or whatever
yeah kind of james bond feeling no the
city center it feels like
this hotel's in la like i don't get out
of la like arya like hotels like that
yeah i mean it has a casino and it's
cool but it feels like i'm in downtown
l.a yeah i need the theme i like the
team a lot yeah i need
i need yeah i need to be around like
people that
are just gambling and their kids are
like dude i want to go to sleep and
they're like one more game you know
because they're gambling damn it you
have weird requests in your life like go
get the [ __ ] go get the [ __ ]
waitress need a hotel where there's a
father he's angry and sad
his wife's cheating on him hey excuse me
where can i find the table where there's
kids and they hate their parents
oh golden nugget down yeah okay thank
you dude i need to see
a [ __ ]
big ass dude just playing slots and his
[ __ ] fat ass wife comes with a fat
tuesday in her hand and she straddles
him and starts [ __ ] grinding him
while they win on the slots and then
they're like daughter comes up and she
goes can you guys not it is so
embarrassing
i just witnessed this a week that's a
true story you guys yeah and which
casino was this one this was in downtown
that sounds right see that's where the
real people are that's where i like
that's where the real people watching is
do you guys have any crazy like gambling
stories like i think the most i've ever
lost like 500 i feel like you guys are
some crazy [ __ ] oh dude i lost probably
like 20 000 dollars uh playing an
ethereum game couple years ago
[Laughter]
easily watch probably like 40 now have
you ever done like the 5 000 on black
you'll walk away you never win or lose i
mean i think i've the most i've lost
maybe like a thousand or two but oh
that's it it's pretty [ __ ] compared to
our old uh clothing sponsor back in the
day
he would be up and down 70 to 90 grand
good god playing what
[ __ ] i don't know he's [ __ ] crazy
just losing money he's like playing
games yeah he was like up and down like
70 90 like all the time and i'm like man
that's so it made me feel like
oh i'm just [ __ ] a kid in a like
kiddie pool that's so strange because
like when it comes to the casino um i'll
probably have a budget of anywhere from
like up to 3 000 right yeah but then
when it comes to crypto
like
i heard you're yeah yeah like i'll [ __ ]
around with like 30 grandish on daily
but it doesn't make me sweat yeah but
then but then but then i'm sweating like
one of the one of the people
but then at the casino though i'm like
a hundred dollars oh [ __ ] i think it's
the physical money that's true like when
you have if you see like 90 g's in front
of you
[ __ ] that looks crazy dude but online
you're just transferring
plus i feel like it's all in chips as
well at the casino so it's like you
really see the stacks of the uh yeah the
chips and it really feels like it's
worth a whole and you see the like the
the severity of it because the minute
you cash in like let's say 10 g's or 20
cash there's [ __ ] four other security
guards come like the whole place changes
everyone's like oh like that right and
they go okay sir we gotta move you to
another table it's like the whole
treatment changes but if you're online
like on coinbase a dollar or a hundred
grand it's like the same experience but
also you know the casino i know what my
odds are
and it's probably it's usually they're
gonna win and i think that's why i feel
like
when we're gambling we're gambling
because the longer you play
you're destined to lose yeah i got this
but it's not the same for crypto [ __ ]
though that's why the longer you play if
you stay in the game the more you can
win yeah that's that's why i feel
different about it yeah for sure
what is it about getting naked too no
dude i got this guy never played
roulette before
he got it but you can see in his face he
was like i don't really know how to do
this i was like look just put on red or
black yeah you put something you win you
just go
like look at around there don't do that
yeah
like after
and everyone's like what dude you won
like four bucks
and that was a big four dollars for me
at that moment okay it's it's the
adrenaline the biggest yeah watch your
mouth mike
the biggest roulette kick in the nuts is
your bedding good and it's black or red
or whatever and then all of a sudden
yeah you're getting double zero you're
like i think oh that [ __ ] existed on the
thing
the best [ __ ] too is that roulette is
like the worst odds in all vegas
and nixton here he's like i'm [ __ ]
come on man
[Music]